The Legend of Zelda, experience the challenge of endless adventure.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
I'm Sean. I'm Joe.
And I'm Sam. Guys, today, a little bit of a big one, if I dare say so.
It's a special day.
It's a special day for good games.
Aw. Yeah.
Right? Like, it's always nice when you have one that you've heard good things about before you go into it.
I have heard of Zelda.
Zelda's kind of hard to have not heard about at this point, right?
Yeah. I think, like, you know, your mom probably thinks that you play as Zelda, but she still
knows what Zelda is.
And I think that's like, that's a test.
Right. You don't play as Zelda?
You don't play as Zelda.
No, you play as Link. Zelda's the name of the sword.
Sean is not finding that out just now.
I, I, I, I, that was low-hanging fruit.
Yeah. Uh, but no, we should talk about that, I guess.
Like, you know, our experience with Zelda going into this, which way, like, you know, listeners
know where each of us are at.
Uh, I'll go last.
So, Sean, tell us a little bit about, like, you know, what you know of the Legend of Zelda
series, if you've played any of the games.
I'm interested. So, I, um, I, this is the first time I've played this game, and the only Zelda game that
I've played any significant portion of, of, uh, prior to this was Breath of the Wild.
Um, I had heard of it.
Um, I was, I had a Super NES, but I never had, like, the Zelda game that came up for that
one. You were, like, the perfect, um, experiment for this, because you played only Breath of
the Wild and only the Legend of Zelda.
That's really interesting. And they also did say that they used influence from this game and that game.
Yeah, I mean, and there's a lot of that, and we'll talk about that later in the episode,
but I think, like, that's just, that's a very interesting case study that you've become.
Yeah, I guess so, yeah.
Uh, Joe? Yeah, in my, in my childhood days of playing only my NES, even though I didn't realize I
was very behind the times, I used to think, like, man, it would be amazing if there was
a game that let you go anywhere.
Like, I honestly used to think, like, but that's impossible.
Like, I don't know how I didn't know about this game, but I was, I was pretty limited to
what I found at garage sales and stuff, you know, I was like six years old.
Sure, yeah. And no one's, no one's giving away their copy of The Legend of Zelda.
Exactly, exactly. You're getting like, um, you're getting a lot of gumshoe.
I played mostly Super Mario Brothers and a bunch of other really bad games that I would
play until I went back to Super Mario Brothers.
But, um, I did eventually discover The Legend of Zelda in high school.
Um, and I, I played it, you know, I never, I hadn't beaten it, but I played it, you know, significantly
and I really loved it.
And it, like, made me, it makes me sad that I don't have nostalgia for it.
Like, I wish that I grew up with this game.
Okay. Um, but I didn't.
Alright. Sam.
Alright. I grew up with this game.
Uh, my first one was Ocarina of Time and Majora's Mask, which we got at the same time,
uh, from a used game store.
That's a good way to get, you know, the two big games at once.
I never ended up beating Majora's Mask because of the whole time mechanic just stressed me
out way too much.
And I tried playing it again with my friend in college and we got pretty far.
We got to the last, uh, dungeon.
And then we died once and we said, oh, we'll pick this up later.
And then we never did. Um, uh, but Ocarina I love.
I think it's a great game.
Uh, then I think I got Minish Cap after that.
And that one's actually really solid.
That's one of my favorite ones, I think.
Yeah. Made by Capcom.
Yeah. Uh, not Nintendo.
So that's like, uh, an interesting way to see like how a different party would handle.
And I know like some people now have floated the idea of like, well, if Ubisoft's gonna
get a chance to make like Mario games, maybe give them a chance to make like a Zelda game.
And I'm like, I don't know.
I don't know about Zelda.
Yeah. I don't think we just give that thing.
Yeah. Uh, what else we got?
So, uh, Ocarina, Majora's Mask, uh, Twilight Princess.
I got up to, I think with the penultimate battle versus Zant.
And it was the same thing where I said, oh, I'll get back to this later.
Like I come up to the fight.
I'll like, I'm a wait and then play it when I'm feeling it.
And I never felt it. Um, uh, we got, uh, the chronological rundown, but like Legend of Zelda.
Legend of Zelda is, is great.
I love it. One of my favorite, one of my favorite games.
I love the atmospheres of all the dungeons.
Um, and just the, the feeling of exploration and everything.
I have Breath of the Wild now and I spent most of my time just like wandering around.
I didn't even beat all the dungeons yet.
Nice. I just keep wandering around.
I grew up with the N64.
Uh, so we got, we had Super Mario 64 at launch and we played that for like forever.
And then in the Christmas of 98, we got Ocarina of time with the gold cartridge.
And I just remember thinking like, oh, this is like the next big thing for video games.
Because all I had ever really known was a big game like Super Mario 64, which of course
now we meant like gold cartridges.
Yeah. Gold cartridges are going to be huge.
Uh, no.
And I remember Ocarina of time just for like the longest, like, I think I played that game
so much. The, the guidebook that we got with it is now completely in pieces.
Like you open it up and there's like maybe seven pages left still intact in the binding,
but it's a crazy game for, for me just because there was so much like exploration and all of
these different things that you can do.
But meanwhile, like to, you know, serious Zelda fans, it was like a step backwards because
it was very linear in some respects.
Like, yes, you could still go to like when you're an adult link, you can go to like the
water temple or the fire temple maybe and do them in different order.
Yeah. But going back now and playing like the original Legend of Zelda, which I first did in like
2014, uh, which is just because like, I didn't really have an NES until that time.
So of course Zelda was on my list and going back to it, I was like, wow, this is really
different than every other Zelda game.
And I played a ton of Zelda games.
This is really different than everything that came after it.
And I wasn't sure how that made me feel, but we'll get into that in the podcast.
So guys, uh, Legend of Zelda released in 1986 in Japan, 87 for the U S and both have the
ability to save Japan.
This is finally an interesting time for us with the ability to save our games.
But Japan, this was supposed to be a launch, um, a launch game for the Famicom disc system.
And, uh, it did not wind up becoming that, but, uh, it is saves on the disc drive.
And then they actually incorporated a battery into the NES cartridge so that we can save over here.
This is a Miyamoto and Tezuka joint.
And if you remember, both those names are the Super Mario Brothers guys.
And that's not surprising at all because they worked on Super Mario Brothers and Legend
of Zelda at the exact same time.
Whoa. In fact, Legend of Zelda was started before Super Mario Brothers because Super Mario Brothers
was more of like a swan song for the cartridge, uh, base thing.
They thought that was the end of cartridges.
You know, they were like, Oh, we got to make one last game for cartridge games.
And little did they know about the N64 10 years later, but they're like, we gotta make one
last game. And so they figured, well, let's use our mascot, Mario, you know, like that's how Super Mario
Brothers came about. Legend of Zelda was actually like a much bigger and planned attack on like, how are we going
to introduce game, you know, like this new generation of gamers to RPGs.
And while Zelda is known for its music, uh, which Koji Kondo has pretty much always done.
He also did the music in this one, but I don't know if it says like, there's not as many tracks
as say, like how I felt about, um, Metroid, you know, the game we covered last week.
There was a lot more like music involved with atmosphere.
I think this is really just like, with the exception of the two main tracks, there's not
much else going on.
And so you kind of have like this overworld theme and this dungeon theme and they're nice
and iconic now, but they looped over and over and over again.
So I would say at least the dungeon theme isn't like grading in the same way that the,
uh, the adventurous overworld theme was a little cheerful.
Um, but yeah, I, I noticed that too.
I was one of like, it's funny cause like it's so forgivable to me, so big, but that is
one of the things I noticed was like, so there's the same for most of the dungeons, exact same
music and the overworld always the same music.
I think it, yeah. And the funny thing is, is I think that comes about because they were originally using like
music that was in the public domain for at least Japan.
And they, in Japan, the way the public domain worked at that time, I don't know if it still
works this way, but you basically, as long as the composer has been dead for 50 years, then
you have access that that music goes into the public domain.
So Nintendo checked and it was the month of release for the Famicom disc system version.
They checked the death of this composer and it was 49 years and 11 months.
And they said, we can't wait another month and we're not going to risk it.
So they asked Koji Kano to pretty much compose those things like that night.
Oh wow.
Do we know like what song was going to be the Zelda theme?
It was a classical, it was a classical piece.
I, I sure I can link it in the show notes.
I don't have it on me right now, but I, the name of it did not ring any bells to me, you
know, nothing like iconic that like everyone in the world would recognize as like this classical.
It's funny too. Cause I mean, I don't know, Sam, maybe you know more about this than I do.
I don't know anything about music, but it seems like they would have to, there'd
be a lot of people who are making it into an, you know, an NES soundtrack and make sure
that it sounds okay.
Still. Right.
It feel almost feels like at that point, you might as well just get someone to hire someone
to just make a song rather than adapt it from.
Yeah. I mean, it would all be scored, but it would be, it's still a process to program it.
I don't know how they did it.
The way that I do chip tunes now that there's like software that someone made, but I'm assuming
it was a lot more complicated back then.
Yeah. I assume it was more like, you know, um, you know, they were actually like writing out
what, you know, like on a, on a score sheet or something like that, what, you know, the
music like condo would do it that way.
And then a programmer would know how to like, you know, put that in.
I don't think I would know himself.
I don't think I was just imagining that programming it.
If you go, if you do that, like one to one like that, it might just not sound good
in the other format.
But yeah. So, uh, you know, that's all we really have to say about the music.
Uh, I would like everyone to break out their manuals.
This way we can talk about the manual of the game.
All right. And if, uh, everyone listening didn't follow Mike's instructions, then I, you may as well
just stop listening right now.
Right. Because, uh, no, we'll make this, we'll make this work.
It is true though.
Like, you know, you kind of, to talk about all the awesome things that are in this manual,
you're going to probably want to pull it up.
And I did put a link in the show notes for you guys.
But if you don't have access to it for whatever reason, we'll try to make this accessible.
But the reason why, you know, we don't usually do a manual section.
Usually Sam just gives us some brief notes on cool parts of the manual.
And then Joe mentions how cool the pause sounds are.
Uh, but the reason why we're doing a manual section for this one is this is actually a
game that was like crucial to have a manual in, in the American version, at least, because
if you think about it, this game really just drops you into its world and says, go do it.
So the manual is kind of like, in some ways, if you were in the legend of, you know, if
you were in Hyrule, you, if you've came across this manual, it would help because it would
have a map and it would have like some instructions.
Like this is really what gave players a sense of like what to do.
Yeah. Go ahead.
I felt like when I first opened it up, it was like a D and D like manual or something.
It's like, here's the map and here's how it works.
And yeah, it's huge.
So, so what are, what is like some standout things for you, Sam on this manual?
Like, um, I, I, I love that enemy art.
Any thoughts on that?
Uh, yeah, I, I thought that I mentioned this before the picture of the Octorok is the most
metal I've ever seen a Zelda enemy.
I think they don't look anything.
It's so different than what they look like in the game and also so different than what
we know them as now.
Like if you look at the, uh, Ocarina of Time Octoroks, they're like, you know, they're
kind of cute compared to these things.
Yeah. This guy looks like he belongs almost in the Metroid universe, you know, like one of mother
brain's assistants or something like that.
Uh, the, the enemy art in general, it feels kind of D and D.
Yeah. Um, or if not D and D, it feels more like belonging to final fantasy, which I think is interesting
because final fantasy hasn't quite come yet.
Uh, I think final fantasy will come, uh, in late 87 for Japan and doesn't come to us until
1990. So sorry, final fantasy fans.
That episode is a while away.
But, um, yeah, so there, there's a bunch of different tips in here about how to use items
and stuff like that.
Um, there's even a section on like a story.
The story, the story got me.
Yeah. The story is pretty crazy.
A back lore essentially that, and they kind of give you that in the, in the startup screen.
There's like a little like, yeah, but this is, this is a lot better.
It's heavy stuff. Yeah. It has a neat, like, um, some great visualization of the map.
Yep. Uh, those illustrations are nice too, because that art is kind of like a link that we never
see anymore. No.
Yeah. Isn't he, he's got like, uh, some really good sideburns.
I remember. Yeah.
He's got some good sideburns.
Uh, and also like, he's, he's a very small little boy.
Like I can't imagine this guy, you know, link being any older than like eight, right?
Like eight's gotta be the cap on how old link is in this game.
Yeah. No, I'd say eight.
Looking at these pictures.
The sideburn. Okay. I'm on page nine.
If you'll, if everyone will flip to page nine, I'm on page nine.
Um, when he's sort of diving into that, uh, that catacomb doorway, um, that's where
I feel it looks like he's got sideburns.
And I would just say he looks like a very short, uh, 24 year old man.
I mean, he's an elf.
So we don't know what they're, what they're age.
There aren't elves. He's a Hylian, right?
Oh, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. And also he's never been a Kokiri.
And I don't think that there are Kokiris in this game.
I know what you're saying. Yeah.
Thank you for, thank you guys for making this an instructional thing for non-Zelda fans.
Uh, Kokiris are just basically like, they live in the lost woods, which in this game,
they don't live in the lost woods.
The lost woods is desolate.
But, but also like, we should talk about that for a brief second.
Cause the manual doesn't even explain this.
Everyone died here.
Like only Zelda is left.
Like not everyone. Oh, that's true.
Yeah. There are the people who live in the caves.
Yeah. And they say that in the manual, it's like, they say that not everyone is dead and that
there are people who live in caves.
Right. Thank you, Sam, the manual for that, uh, that adjustment.
And that is true. I love the, the guys in the caves because they range from everything from like merchants
to like just giving away stuff because like, you're, you know, you're the last hope to then
just straight up being like, Hey, fix that door.
You just, you just broke into my cave.
Like give me money to pay for that door.
Also in the manual, it says like, don't get ripped off and don't like buy stuff from people
when they ask for too much.
And cause there are some places where it's just really expensive to buy things.
And they're like, don't buy too much expensive stuff.
And this isn't like Kid Icarus where you can shout into your, uh, Famicom controller
to haggle the prices.
Not for that. I forgot about that.
Oh my God. But you can shout into the Famicom controller to get rid of those other enemies.
In Zelda you're talking about?
In Zelda, those cat head or bunny head looking enemies.
Oh yes. Yes.
Yeah. So they could have added the haggling feature.
Not it, but Sean, not in the NES version.
Only in the Japanese version.
Yeah. It's similar to, uh, I think you could also, um, use the warp whistle that way.
Or maybe I'm misremembering that, but I thought you could use the warp whistle by blowing into
the microphone as well.
Don't quote me on that.
Anyway, I think that the, I think that the manual is lower looking at for the illustrations,
but obviously guys, the big hook is that the manual also came with a giant map of just
what you need to get started.
Yeah. Isn't that nice?
Like, like this isn't a map that spoils the entire game for you.
It doesn't tell you where dungeons six, seven, eight, and nine are.
It doesn't even mention a dungeon nine.
Right. Like, it just says like, here's enough that just in case, and they even actually have in,
if you get like a brand new copy, which nostalgia did not get.
But if you got like a brand new copy of this game and opened it up for the first time in 87,
when you open it, the map is actually contained in like a small little package that says like,
kind of like, and this isn't verbatim, but like, don't break this seal unless you desperately need the help.
Right. In case of emergency.
Right. Exactly.
Like only use this map as a last resort.
And I think that's like a testament to how much they trusted gamers to like use, you know,
use like judgment on whether it was time to use the map.
Like, okay, they've given me this much information just in the manual, but I still haven't necessarily found the first dungeon.
You know, like, I think it's time for me to open that map, you know, whereas like, if you're finding enough things,
chances are you don't need that giant map to get through the rest of the game.
That's been the manual section, guys.
You can fold those bad boys up now.
Turn the page. Put them away.
Okay, guys, this isn't like a pop quiz or anything like that.
But can anybody tell me the state of RP or role playing games in general before Zelda comes out on the NES?
It's pretty rough. Yeah, like, like, how are you?
How are you? How are you RPGing?
Um, you are how?
Okay, so you mean just like what sort of what's the medium?
Yeah, what's the medium?
What's the mechanics like like on the NES?
Is it happening?
Like what's going on? I think that this is a you should still be on tabletop if you want an actual RPG experience in this day and age.
Um, you basically have, uh, very minimal inventories, uh, very low effort stories, just I guess experiences just coming into its own.
I don't know. Yeah, I would feel like they would try and like try and almost emulate what's happening on like on like a PC like a text based adventure, which always is very bad on an NES.
Like, you know, you got to kind of use like a an arrow and everything.
You know, it's just I feel like they would they would try and be very text based.
Yeah, I mean RPGs at this point, you know, like pre pre Zelda are not really happening on consoles.
And if they are, they're happening in the examples that we talked about, like, like a Rygar where it's like mostly an action adventure game with like some fun RPG elements.
Yeah, the real RPGs are happening on on tabletop.
You know, D&D is a huge thing that is people are hearing about in Japan.
There's a lot of success and stuff like that.
But also in Japan, computer gaming is a big thing in America.
You know, certain people who are like diehard computer gamers will tell you that computer gaming was big, you know, in America, too, but not on the same level.
And so in Japan, they were much more experienced with like RPG, like, you know, RPG games on the computer.
And so Miyamoto actually wanted to find a way of like, well, RPG games are starting to become this popular genre.
So how does Nintendo tackle it?
You know, what is what can they do?
And I think that they find a happy medium here with Zelda.
Like how how RPG do you guys feel like this game is?
There is no experience points.
Well, this is the most RPG game we've played so far.
OK, you're going on record with that.
I'm going to.
Yeah, OK, no, I'm not saying you're wrong.
I would fight you on that.
I think that this is.
Yeah, there's no experience points, but but you feel like almost in a more organic way, you feel like because of what you've collected and because of parts of the adventure you've gone on, you got a new sword, you got a new, you know.
Yeah, I mean, we're not quite at quest design yet, but we still have we still have upgrading your gear.
Like, I feel like the heart containers are a way of experience.
You've got nonlinear progression.
Yeah, you can choose any which way you want to go.
All of the dungeons in the game, with the exception of like two that you need a specific item to get to are available to you right from the start.
You're not supposed to go there and it's going to be very tough for you.
But the game isn't saying, hey, you can't go here.
So what I mean, I'm not saying that you were implying this, but do you have a game that we have played so far that you would consider more RPG?
No, I think this is definitely like I think this is controversial.
But in terms of like the timeline for right now in video gaming, Zelda is an RPG, you know, like at this point in video gaming nowadays, Zelda is not an RPG.
It's almost like I wouldn't even call it a JRPG.
It's its own. It's its own category.
It's like it's a third person action game.
But are they action games really like like like I think of third party action games as third person action.
Wait, what did you say?
Third person action games. I think it was more as like, you know, an Assassin's Creed or like.
Yeah, but they weren't always like that.
I think an Uncharted.
So even like the newest at which I haven't played, but even the new Assassin's Creed, is that not like a third person action game with RPG elements?
I don't know. I haven't played Assassin's Creed since Black Flag, but I would say that there are some RPG elements insofar as I think most action games now have borrowed as much RPG elements as they have like games about around this time.
I agree. I think like with the exception of platformers nowadays, it's like almost every game has some RPG elements involved in it.
And I feel like that's where this would land comparing it to everything now.
I think. Yeah, exactly.
And I think kind of where I where I was trying to say is like, you know, like when we talk about Pokemon, it's like, is that an RPG?
It's like, no, it's a Pokemon game.
Yeah, that's how I feel about Zelda.
It's like, no, it's not like that's not a genre.
It's just a Zelda thing.
I think Pokemon and there's Zelda likes squarely a corner of the RPG.
Interesting. So you would call that a JRPG.
You would call Pokemon a JRPG.
I would not. I think JRPGs are different.
I think that RPG is a very all encompassing and like people have been fighting about this for decades.
Right. That's why I thought it'd be fun to bring it to our conversation.
But I do think that Pokemon falls squarely in RPG territory.
If you want me to be honest, I think at the end of the day, as long as it's called a video game, it's fun.
I don't care what genre you want to put it into.
You know, it's like, like, I really don't care.
I was just more being like a semantics thing.
Oh, no, I dig it. I think that like.
I'm all about genres.
Yeah, exactly.
Zelda has created like its own thing.
And it's funny how like the Zelda games today, with the exception of the new Breath of the Wild, the Zelda games today aren't really like this first Legend of Zelda game.
So that's why I'm saying like for right now where we put Legend of Zelda like on the timeline, this is an RPG game.
Yeah. You know, like this is it could be its own thing, too.
It could just be this is Zelda.
This is all I know, you know, and that works, too.
So I mean, you get to name your character.
So, I mean, that's cool.
Yeah, you do. I didn't even realize that.
Yeah, that is something that I just kind of looked over.
You get to name the character and you can name the character Zelda and unlock an entirely new section of the game.
But we'll get into that later.
Let's talk a little bit more about the game now because we've kind of been skirting the obvious topics here.
So the game itself.
Yeah, the game itself here.
Let's just talk about the sense of adventure in this game.
You get dropped off in the middle of nowhere, essentially to you.
You know, you don't know where you are on the map yet and you have no weapons.
What are your guys thoughts right now?
I mean, I I love the fact that.
Every screen, it feels like it just like the world just exists around you.
It doesn't feel like it exists for you or to like push you in a direction.
It feels like this is the way the world is.
This is the way this screen is.
And you just have to deal with it.
You don't have a sword like you better go find a sword.
Like it makes it feel more like an experience that's happening to you.
Like, you know what I mean?
Like you're navigating a world that would exist with or without you is giving is giving the player the sword.
Like if you would have started with the sword, would that have been bad game design?
I think that for the sake of this game, it would go kind of contrary to what they're going for.
Like, I feel like this game is all about kind of guiding the player in a certain direction and then letting them go.
So like for me, when I would go to a screen and there would be tons of enemies on that screen and I only have three hearts and I'm just starting out, I would just turn around.
Right, because you know you're not going to last in that.
And that's cool knowing that.
But if I got a sword from the beginning, it's like, oh, OK, I'm going to I'm going to go kill stuff because I have a sword and I feel strong.
But that's not what happens when you get the sword.
When you get the sword, it's the guy says it's dangerous to go alone.
So, I mean, this is something, you know?
Yeah. Yeah, I don't think giving you the sword would have been bad game design, but I think it's much better game design to not give you the sword.
Yeah, I think I was going to say exactly what you just said.
I don't know how I would have approached this game if I had if it didn't have if if its reputation didn't precede it as it does.
Like if I went in a direction and there were a lot of enemies, I probably would have just thought like, well, it expects me to beat all these enemies now because it's like right next to where I started or only a couple of screens away.
But no, I think that that choice, while it's not it's not exactly a negative if it didn't exist, like the choice of not giving you a weapon.
It does sort of condition you to say like, hey, you're not going to be you're not going to be given anything.
Like, I mean, yeah, there's some it's it does sort of there's an invisible hand guiding you in a way.
But by and large, you are just sort of on your own.
Yeah, I think I hard agree with the idea that like not giving the player the sword show like teaches a but it's almost like a tutorial in some ways.
Getting the sword is like the only tutorial in the game because it's telling you like you need you need to find items.
You need to explore.
You need to enter caves.
You need to look like you need to look for this stuff.
This is what this game is.
Because this is how you're going to get around in this world.
And I think if you start with the sword, your your next thought isn't necessarily, well, what should I get next?
You know, it's where your first thought is, where should I go next?
Whereas when you don't have the sword immediately, you need something to do.
You're going to go out one screen if you don't go into that cave for whatever reason.
You're going to go out to another screen.
You're going to find enemies.
You're not going to be able to do anything.
And then you're going to think like, I got to go, you know, like I got to go find a weapon.
Right. Like, that's the cool thing about not giving the player the sword.
Yeah, I will say this.
This is just a funny thing, though.
I say that that would work.
But I'm also the same idiot that got Pokemon Blue in 98 and couldn't figure out how to start that game because I didn't go into the grass because I was told not to go there.
I never had that encounter with Professor Oak after you take your first step into Route 2.
So I'm that idiot.
So I'm sure there were some players who went out there and they're like, I don't even have a sword.
I can't even fight.
This game is dumb. I mean, as we talk, you will find that I am right there with you.
Okay. Okay, great.
So this end of adventure is great.
Sean, you talked about an invisible hand.
Do you want to get into that at all about like how this game pushed you in certain directions?
Like, do you want to talk about like a memory?
Oh, yeah. Well, I mean, like just in.
Okay. So you start off in a field.
Even in the first screen, it's there.
Start off in a field.
There are three ways to go.
But the thing that draws your attention the most is just this hole in the wall.
And I mean, maybe I'm only speaking for myself, but I feel like that hole in the wall is a more interesting feature than these paths just going off in either direction.
Those paths can go anywhere.
And that also kind of guarantees me something.
Yeah. And also at this point, I mean, it might be kind of silly to say, but at this point, you don't know that walking to the edge of the screen will move you to another screen.
You don't know. You're like, this is all.
The only thing you see that you know is a place you can go is the cave.
And the rest is like you've got to experience it to see if you can.
I think it's a little intuitive that there isn't a barrier there.
But I see what you mean.
Right, right. But yeah, most people's first movement will go into the cave.
And I think that in itself is just that little guiding hand of, hey, here's a feature.
It's the first thing we're showing you.
Why don't you check it out?
And I don't think that they always follow this rule because there's a lot of really crappy design later on.
Okay. In terms of just like obfuscation.
But I think by and large, like the overworld map is a pretty intuitive map.
Joe, any points in the game where you felt like the game was pushing you in a certain direction that Sean didn't mention?
Give me a second.
I got something. You got one?
Okay. Yeah. I think that even the size of the paths push you in certain directions.
Like the first dungeon to get there, you just go straight.
And that's the biggest, widest path there is.
Between the trees, right? Yeah.
Yes. But on the main screen, like the first screen that you go to, there are these tiny little paths to the left and the right.
But there's a really wide path in front of you.
And the way the cave is kind of almost like on an angle,
it makes it so that when you leave the cave, you kind of want to keep going forward.
You know?
So I think that there are like little natural little nudges.
Like the landscape kind of makes you want to check out certain things and avoid other things.
And it's not like your next objective is ever like so far away from you.
Your next objective is relatively well placed to where you have to go next.
The game doesn't really rely on the player going from the, you know, the far southeast all the way up to the northwest.
You know? Like it doesn't really happen that way.
And there was a time where I tried that.
And when I first started, I said, okay, I'm not going to look at the manual.
I just, I know that there's like a map at the bottom of it just because I've heard about this game so much.
I'm just going to explore.
And I fought a Lionel.
Oh my goodness. In one of my first playthroughs.
I think I had two hearts and I see a cave.
And I'm thinking, okay, this guy's in front of a cave.
I'm going to try and get past him.
And he just one shots me and I'm done.
So you must have went all the way up north.
Yeah. Okay.
I know where you were. Yeah.
Very cool. Blue Lionel too.
So they're even tougher. Oh wow.
Okay. Joe, did you have anything?
Yeah, I think so. I just want it to be a little more obvious than the others.
But a lot of times in the, I think it only happens in the dungeons.
When you clear a room of enemies, it'll give you like one bomb in the middle of the room.
And there's a lot of walls that like don't, that there are secret areas that you can bomb a hole through.
Totally. So I think that's like your cue to say, hey, maybe try this out on these walls.
And I think there was actually like one or two times where it just didn't work.
Yeah. I mean, there are plenty of walls.
I mean, because theoretically each wall that doesn't have a door already to it is a wall you can try on, you know.
And it's amazing that they put those in there as like, you know, things for you to discover.
Because you can skip like large parts of dungeons by going, by bombing those walls.
And I will say that on the flip side of it, I think that there were some times where there's a bombing, a wall that's bombable or like a bush that's burnable.
That they don't give you really any clues.
Yeah. And I'm not sure.
Like some of that I feel like is like, well, there's just a lot of guess and check and not necessarily like a lot of like figure it out yourself.
But in some cases, I think there were like good leading hints.
Yeah, I think an opposite opinion of the invisible hand thing is that it's really weird.
I thought at least that when you get items in this game, no one, no one explains anything.
And it's up to you to try it out and figure it out.
And I think like, you know, the first one that stuck out for me was the candle because you get the blue candle from a merchant, not in a dungeon where it's dark.
So you're using this thing for a while is like, oh, OK, this thing's like a flame that I can only use once.
Like, you know, I'm not really sure what's going on.
And then, you know, there's like a moment because you get that pretty early.
And the first dungeon that does blackout, I think, isn't isn't until level four.
And you get to one of those dark rooms.
And the first thing I thought of was like, what if I just light the room up?
Like, you know, like, why don't I just use the candle?
And it's so smart to do it that way because the easier approach would have been the blue candle is the item of that dungeon in level four that you have to go find.
And then that's like explicitly telling you like, hey, you know, this candle is the way to kind of like how the ladder is given to you in level five, level five or six.
The ladder is given to you because it's like that's the only way you're going to be able to get across the water to finish the rest of the dungeon.
Like, you need that.
And that one was like, this is such a very specific use case thing that I think the ladder for me was the only item that I wasn't actually impressed by because it was it was more of a Metroid thing, you know, where it's like you can't open these doors until you get those missiles.
You know, it's like you can't cross this until you get that ladder.
Right. Similar to the raft, actually, too.
If we can talk about the raft for a second.
Yeah. That was kind of strange.
I think that has a similar element.
I know. I know you guys didn't care for in Rygar, which.
Yeah. There's like a there's like a thing that.
Oh, yeah. Trigger is like this is where you can use the grappling hook.
Like this is where you can use the raft only.
I'm like, but it's a raft and that's water.
You can't put the raft on water.
It's also weird, though, too, because you get the raft and then it's like it's not usable in the dungeon.
Right. And yes, like you get it in the dungeon right before you're supposed to go to the raft dungeon.
But like I wouldn't have thought like, you know, like go check that out.
It's just something that's more or less going to happen.
Thankfully, they didn't map it to be like it's just like as long as you have the raft in your item inventory, you can go to the level four dungeon now.
But since we're talking about, you know, the order of these dungeons with them, I'm giving out crazy numbers.
Nobody really like did them in the exact order.
Right. Well, OK, so let me tell you a little story about how I play this game.
Make this as long as it has to be.
I want to hear it. OK, so I move the game, go in, get the sword.
Everything's going great so far.
I end up going to the west and I'm in the woods and I find my way to like a hole in the wall.
And there's like an old lady and she's like, hey, give me money.
I'll tell you a secret. So I'm like, I got some cash.
So I pay for the rupees.
I got some rupees. So I ask for the most expensive secret and she gives me some directions.
And so I follow the directions to the lost woods and I have three hearts and I go right into the sixth dungeon.
And I'm sort of just like taken aback by what's around me.
And I get through like maybe two screens before I drop dead.
Now you saw the level six thing and knew you were in the sixth dungeon or you just thought like I'm that.
OK, I'm just making sure that you didn't think like, oh, this is the first dungeon.
This is tough. Yeah.
I'm like, OK, level six.
I know that there's nine dungeons just from knowing about this game a little bit.
And then I died.
And then I'm like, oh, I guess that was not supposed to happen.
Actually, I knew going there that like, oh, I'm probably just way out of my element right now.
So then I went back and I proceeded to find the first two dungeons and those were relatively easy.
Especially after having encountered the sixth one.
And I feel like, oh, I'm well on my way.
And then I get to the third one and that's a little bit tougher, but I get through that one.
And now I'm lost because I didn't even know that there were items hidden in the other dungeons.
So you hadn't gotten the boomerang or the arrow?
OK, so I got a boomerang because I think it was just dropped by an enemy.
Yeah, you have to clear out a whole room and the boomerang will just show up.
Yeah, but the other ones were like, I didn't even see a screen like that.
Like that screen where you go down the ladder and then pick up the item and then go back up the ladder.
Like I never saw that.
OK, so I that's as much as I played.
Wow. OK, I mean, I knew that I was missing something.
But at this point, I didn't have enough time to keep going.
Right, right, right. And I and I didn't want to look up a walkthrough.
And I knew that like there was more that I could have done to do this.
But yeah, I think this is I think this is a counterpoint to I'm not saying that it should be dumbed down.
But I think it makes more sense design wise to put a barrier in your dungeon that you have to get the item to cross.
And you'll see them do that in every Zelda game.
Yeah, it was actually something that felt like it stands out to you almost that like you get an item in the dungeon and need it in another dungeon.
Like it's like it feels like most games do it the other way.
It's like weird that you get this raft and like, yes, like I said, it helps you with the very next dungeon.
But it's like it's weird that it doesn't have any application within the same dungeon.
And I think that will.
And yeah, I think that there are positives for having it be like it's not needed and you have to find it in order to progress later.
But I think if you could if you could like just make sure it'll eliminate it'll eliminate frustration to the people that got into my position.
And then you have these opportunities of like, OK, maybe have this as something that you need to get to some secondary item that you don't need.
And there are a lot of those.
And like like in Metroid, how half the upgrades were sort of optional.
Right. And you could have those applications be there, like how you can just bomb through walls.
Like I I've tried a lot of walls and I think only like three of them worked for me.
And you only get so many bombs.
It's not like in Metroid where you have the little bombs infinitely.
You can only just use one at a time.
So I don't know. I guess I played the game pretty wrong, but I still enjoyed myself playing it.
And I like that you stuck with it, though, too, is like I'm not going to look up a manual.
Like this is my experience in this game.
You know, there's something to appreciate about that rather than resorting to like I think you should eventually go back.
No, I mean, I'm going to go back and finish this game.
But I think that there's something to be said about the fact that you didn't just be like, OK, well, I'm going to figure out the right way to do this.
Like you kind of just said, like, this is the way I'm playing the game.
So I'm just going to keep going as far as I possibly can.
And that's something I wanted to talk about, actually, because I had a smaller version of that experience.
And I don't remember which dungeon.
But at a certain point I had to there was an item I was missing that I needed to go on.
And I kind of realized, like, I missed it in another dungeon.
So I had to like almost go on.
I'm sort of twisting a negative into a positive here.
But my rose colored glasses were telling me, like, I got to go on like a little side quest.
Like, this will be fun. So I had to go on like another adventure, like, just to figure out, like, back into the dungeon that I already been into and like figure out what did I miss?
Like, what else was here?
And something about the fact that, like, I knew, like, I would come in today and talk to you guys and you guys wouldn't have had that same experience I had.
It was kind of cool to me.
I was like, you know, we all will have had different adventures.
Yeah. And it's like, I can't think of another example where so far we're like, it's really been the case where it's like we have very different.
I mean, you know, maybe like branching paths.
We've been playing very, very limited scope games up until like.
Right. And this feels like it's just like not just like, oh, I went on a different path or like it was a whole different experience.
Like I had like a different mission.
And yeah, I'm talking it up a little bit.
But I thought that was I thought that was kind of cool.
Yeah. I kind of have a stray thought just about dungeons in general.
And that's that I think that I was so appreciative that when I died in a dungeon, they brought me back to the start of the dungeon and not to the start of the overworld.
Oh, yeah. Because it just kind of I don't know.
It was it was one of the things that this is the first one of the first games, I think, that I've played where when I die, I don't feel like this is like too hard.
OK. I feel like it's like it's hard, but it's fair hard.
You know, like you felt like you shouldn't have been there when you died or you just felt like I earned that death.
Just like I like I earned it.
You know, it felt like if like the punishment and rewards of this felt very modern to me.
It didn't feel like arcade esque.
It is more.
I mean, I think that we have we've touched upon like having the difficulty feel earned and how like, oh, that death was my fault.
We've touched upon that.
Yeah. But in terms of the difficulty of this game where you don't really lose anything when you die.
Yeah. And that's great.
And that is very modern.
I'm not saying it's good or bad, but it is very modern.
Yeah. And one thing that's very smart with this game that Sam brought up is that it takes you back to the startup screen, you know, like the the place where you found the sword, you know.
And I think what's smart about that is that if you died in the overworld, that kind of nudges you to say like, oh, maybe I should try a different direction.
You know, like I was really overwhelmed.
And you'll know when you're really overwhelmed when you didn't just die because you were being careless.
Like I was really overwhelmed, like you were saying with the Lynels, you know, like I was being.
Like rampaged on.
I need to find a better way to go about this path.
I'm going to try this way this time.
You know, it's like that's something neat, because if they would have just loaded you back into like the screen before it, you'd be encouraged to just keep charging back in until it works.
Yeah. And you it does give you three hearts to start with again when you die, which I think is cool because it's like a little bit of a punishment.
But it's not like you're as strong as you possibly could be.
Right. And I like that they respawn all the enemies, too.
So you have to redo it.
And it's not like they it's watered down.
I don't know. I was just really impressed with the with just the feeling it gave me.
Totally. You know, I think as far as difficulty like on the NES goes, I think this is maybe still more difficult than a lot of games now.
But I think it like kind of nails that like that perfect medium where it's like not.
Yeah. It feels difficult, but doable.
And I like that. I think this for me, this is like the template.
Like this is what I want other NES games to be like.
Difficulty wise. And I think one thing to get back to, Joe, since since we're talking about the difficulty and how like things aren't necessarily spelled out for you and everybody has different paths is that that was completely Miyamoto's intention.
At the very least, if not Nintendo's like the entire team's intention was to make it so that you're playing this game.
I'm playing this game. We go to school together.
We are at work together.
Like, you know, like we're friends, whatever the situation is.
And you're playing that game at your house and I'm playing the game at my house.
And then we can bond over it in a way where I'm like, you know, oh, I'm on level four right now.
And you're like, oh, I just got past that last night.
I had to do this.
And then all of a sudden I have that eureka moment where it's like now this like tail is being passed down to me.
Yeah. And I'm like, oh, OK, that's what I have to do.
Right. Like there's something nice about that.
And not that that can't be done in every single game.
Right. Like it's what makes it interesting here is that there is a different way to go about it where Joe can be on.
Like the level four dungeon and I can be on the level six dungeon, but I haven't finished his level four dungeon.
I just happened to wind up at that one first.
And so I have information that's worthy to give to Joe and he has information that's worthy to give to me rather than, well, I'm just in the next level and I'm doing better than you right now.
So here's what you need to do to get ahead of me.
It's like we can be in different spots and still share the same, you know, like useful information.
Right. Bye.
I think that may have been what
the more
oblique ways to progress
like maybe that was supposed to be
the last resort
maybe not even the last resort but that was designed to be
like okay they'll talk and somebody will
find it. Right we don't need to test this game
they'll figure it out eventually
It reminds me of like in PT
when like the only way to beat
PT is to do this like ridiculous
sequence of movements and
I think there was a point you had to shout into your
controller and
then it'll play the Silent Hills
trailer. I don't know if you ever read anything
about that. Never. No I've actually been
too scared to even watch a gameplay of
PT. Oh my god I played PT.
It's great but anyway it's the same like
everybody the community is playing this game not just you
So guys I want to talk about
Dodongo Dislikes Smoke.
Yeah that actually gave me a hint
Yeah okay
like I'm like okay no bombs
but I I love it
yes exactly it's
it's so
clearly like Japanese poorly translated
to you know English
but I brought that up as like
just a way to segue into
these hints in general
because I was wondering
are there any other
like that one stands out for me
as just like a fun one
that also happened to work
but were there any other ones
that stood out for you guys?
I mean like you mentioned
getting the riddle to the lost woods
Yeah and that's like a huge one too
because there's no other way
that you're I mean like really
there's not even a good chance
you're gonna guess it though
if you think about it
like there's a ton of combinations
You can you can luck into it
but there were a lot that didn't work
like I mean the ones that
I don't really I'm not saying that I came across these
but when I watched
some people play this game
to get a gist of what I was missing
things like that
that easternmost peninsula one
Yeah the eastmost peninsula
one is a famous
like it has nothing to do
with what was actually being said
in the Japanese version
the Japanese version
mentions something about
that bows
that arrows cost rupees
which is something that you'll find out
you know on your own
using the bow and arrow
like you'll realize
that it's taking rupees away from you
but the eastmost peninsula thing
is now like people thought like
oh they're taught
like this is a secret
like we have to decode this
is there a peninsula on this map
there is I can't remember
and like you know
it can be taken like
a ton of ways
you know there is that dungeon
and then
there's the
the money making game too
on that eastmost peninsula side
the money making game being the thing
where like you just choose
a rupee thing
and then it's either like you lose or you gain some
and that's like a very risky game
that I didn't feel like
playing that much because rupees are hard
to get in this game
but another one
that I really liked was the
the waterfall
the waterfall one
because I thought like that was really cool
because there's
you know there's pretty much like
a 99% chance
at that point that you have not
like unless you've played this game before
you are not thinking
I should be exploring
a waterfall and then this guy is like
did you get the sword
from the old man on top of the waterfall
and you're like
no like I didn't
and then you go up there
and he's like take this if you're worthy
and you might not be
yeah you might not be worthy
and I like that it doesn't tell you why
that is interesting
and I think that's the same
thing as it's heart containers
but I think it's the same
thing as like items I don't hate that it
doesn't tell you but it's also just like
not necessarily nice
because that's like a form of backtracking
that I don't want to do
whereas like the item
it's like I've acquired it
and now I just have to find its use
I don't have to go back
and find the item
again and again each time I get a heart
container which I wouldn't have
thought anyway but like each time I get
anything in the game
or beat another dungeon
which is the right way
to go about it because dungeons
are the main way
of getting heart containers
each time I get a dungeon
I'm gonna go back
to that place and see if I'm worthy now
right I think that
that was a cool way
of doing it just for your like
your imagination's sake
where it's like even if you
I don't know if it tells you in the manual
that you need heart containers
but if you don't know
you need heart containers
you're just organically
getting more heart containers
as you go so you
it kind of feels like
oh now I'm worthy
like it just feels like that
even if you don't know
what actually
the game is recognizing
as making you worthy
yep and then there's
Dig Dogger hates
certain kinds of sound
and I thought that
that was really cool because that's telling you
basically like you know
you can try all you want
on this boss to defeat him
but unless you use
the warp whistle nothing's gonna happen
you know
I like how we call it
the warp whistle oh my goodness
I just said that
yeah you said it twice now
yeah wow that is so funny
and the first time nobody called me out on it
so I'm gonna assume
that you all agree that it's more
the warp whistle
than it is it should be an ocarina
honestly the first time
I think it didn't even
affect me because I was like
yeah the warp whistle but it sounds like
okay yeah
and then the last
yeah exactly
the last hint
aim at the eyes of Goma
that was the last one
that really stuck with me
because again that's like using the arrow
but it only has one eye
so I was like
what's the other eye they're talking about
what's the secret that I have to learn
oh yeah aim at the eyes which one's Goma
which uh
Goma's the spider
oh okay
that closes that
little blinky eye yeah
and when it's closed
you can't do anything but when it's open
shoot that arrow
and I think it's a one hit kill
uh no I think it takes a few
okay but those are some
sturdy eyelids
yeah Dodongo's the one hit kill
I felt so bad
killing Dodongo we'll talk about it
yeah it's just cause like
you seem so frightened
whenever you well like
I walk into
the room and I see this
like little dinosaur
in the middle of it
and I'm like oh cool
dinosaurs are here
you know and I'm looking at the map
in the top left corner
and I forget that
the last room
is always the Triforce room
you know so I'm thinking like
oh this must be like
a mini boss or something
and the real boss
is next door like
cause I played Ocarina of Time
where King Dodongo
is this huge
huge dinosaur
right and so I see this
little orange guy in the middle of the screen
and I'm like oh that's cute
maybe I hit this guy
and then like he like turns big
or like the real one
comes out or something
and so I hit him
a couple times I throw the bomb out
and then I hit him again and he dies
and then the heart container
comes out and I'm thinking like
oh no that was it
he doesn't attack
he's just walking around
I felt really bad
and you feed him the bomb
and he's like ooh thank you
and he eats it and he's like
oh what happened I interpreted his
facial expression
as just like
ouch that hurts
like every time you hit him
like it's just ow I'm hurting
he doesn't like lash out
it feels really bad
you're just slaughtering
this poor animal
huh yeah
Dodongo was
Dodongo was definitely
the one I felt bad about
out of any of them
but also I just thought
it was weird that like
bosses
between levels
would just like
they vary
between like one to two hit KOs
and like impossible
like eight hit
monsters like you know
like yeah when you blow the whistle
and then he becomes weak
it's really just a matter of
you know landing a couple shots
when you fight
the three headed dragon
it's an onslaught
that goes on forever
and you have to be close to it
because boomerang doesn't do anything
arrows don't do anything
unless you're at like
full health oh yeah
and you can shoot the sword
yeah because that's how I beat him
yeah I mean that's the most efficient way
but I am
there's something about
my clutch factor
in this game
where I'm really good
when I'm at low hearts
but when I have full hearts
I am so quick to lose
just even a half a heart
to not have the ability
to shoot off my swords
which we can talk about
as like that's a weird thing
right shooting the sword
yeah even the wing sword
has that power
yeah it should be like
reserved for the magic sword
but no I would be
I would also be pretty upset
if they didn't have that ability
I'm like that's a big
big feature
I'm not saying again
we're not about to break down
like how realistic
is Zelda I'm just saying
that I did think it was weird
that it wasn't like
you know when you get
the magic wand finally
and that shoots out
like two light arcs
you know I think like
if it would have been something more like that
I could have bought into
the idea more instead of like
the idea that like
I'm throwing my sword
right or like something about it
and then it explodes
speaking of the magic wand
I thought it was really cool
that you just have
the same exact weapon
that these enemies
you've been fighting have
like that that's
I feel like that's something
that you don't see a lot even in games now
is that with the orb like the
no no no no
you know those wizards
that like teleport around
and they shoot those like
boom boom
oh yeah you get that exact weapon
like it's just it's just like one of theirs
and it doesn't harm them
no which you would think
it would be like their weakness
they've mastered it
yeah but you would think
gameplay game design wise
you'd think like oh this is you got that
now you can fight those guys
but like logically
yeah that doesn't hurt
we know all about this wand
we have to pivot against it
right right but it is good
in that dungeon because then you can
take down the like-likes
which I have no idea why they're called that
but you can take down
the like-likes with that
from far away
while you're dealing with the other guys
with your sword the like-likes
are the they're trunk looking things
that slither around the room
the tombs that eat your shield
yeah maybe the scariest enemy
take the shield
yeah I used to hate those
in every Zelda game
every Zelda yeah and they're also
just like gross too
yeah they're really they're orange right
yes okay okay
especially I have like
the N64 version of them
stuck in my head
where they're like
these giant things
that are like pulsating
and they like
absorb you
and your guys making
like creepy noises
while you're inside so whenever I see one
second worst enemy
next to the Redeads
I'm just hungry oh yeah
I'm just hungry
okay so we're not
going to talk about every single enemy
but since we're on the subject of enemies
I know we were talking
about Lynels earlier
and yes they are like
theoretically like
the blue Lynel
is like the toughest enemy
like in terms of
centaur thing yes exactly
yeah but if we're being real
for a minute the Darknuts
are the worst
okay and I don't expect you guys
just to know who that is
like because I said
the Darknuts but the Darknuts
are the guys who have the shield
as well and a sword
and they're like in full armor
then yeah that's who I was thinking
okay and you can only
attack them from behind
or the side right
yeah or the side but they always
turn towards you
yes they're always
turning towards you you don't hurt them
when you walk into them
but they hurt you when you walk
you know is that the whole thing
again and you know
as a guy who didn't really have
the ability to shoot
his sword all the time
because I was really bad
at keeping full health
you gotta get close those things
caused more deaths
than anything else
in this game for me any boss in this game
I didn't even die from Ganon so much
as I did from these Darknuts
they're riddled
level 3 is like
riddled with them too
level 3? do bombs work on those guys?
bombs do work on them
but again you only get 8 bombs
at a max at any particular time
I think it only counts as like 1 hit
but eventually
you get 16 right?
yeah yeah but I guess what I'm saying
is that like
they didn't do enough
for like to Sean's point
they still only count as like 1 hit
and they're lucky if that bomb
is making a connection
they're still quite the nuisance
it takes forever
to take those guys down
whereas at least with the Lynels
it's like any direction
just keep your distance
for the most part
you know hit them with the boomerangs
this way they freeze
it's like can't do that
with these guys
I think it's funny
like facing the Lynels
because the only other time
I've played them was in Breath of the Wild
that's the only other time
they show up Sam? well there you go
that's very funny
and one of the many
callbacks to the original
Legend of Zelda is in Breath of the Wild
with the Lynels and the Lynels
in Breath of the Wild
are certainly the hardest enemy
in that game that's a true testament
to like
just the funny thing about
Lynels in Breath of the Wild
we'll make this in Breath of the Wild
but like in Master Mode
which was an added DLC thing
on the Great Plateau
where you start that's like the tutorial thing
the first time you play it through but if you play on Master Mode
they put a Lynel
on the Great Plateau
and he'll just like
completely ruin your day
wow so I think that's just like
yeah we made this mode
a lot harder but I have a lot of complaints
about Master Mode so that's not an endorsement
to buy the DLC what did you look up?
I just looked at the manual
you just looked at the manual
yeah nobody went to GameFAQ?
no I looked some things up online
especially towards like
as we were getting close
to recording this episode
I was like alright I gotta start
looking some things up I can't think of
too many specific things
but it was mostly just like
things that you'd probably
have to get a hint from an old man somewhere
like where do I find this
or where do I you know I'm locked out of this area
how do I get you know
how do I get through
the Lost Woods? I looked that up
because that's
because you didn't want to pay the woman
I couldn't even remember
if I even ran across the woman
or knew that that was what she was going to tell me
yeah she is to be fair she is in the bottom left corner
but does she tell you I'll tell you how to get
through the Lost Woods or does she just
pay me and I'll tell you a secret
because the last person
I paid that had told me something
I had already done
so you were like
I'm not wasting my money twice
I will say that
for this playthrough
I did not
but that's because
I mostly knew everything
going into this playthrough
but for my very first playthrough
I did look up about
the this is an often complained
thing about the tree
that you have to burn
to get to the seventh dungeon
and I kind of felt like
after I looked it up
I was like yeah but I could have
figured that out like so many people
it is in a weird spot
that was the second dungeon
I found by accident
I didn't do it until much later
but it just it looks like
a burnable bush
and it's also a dead end
like it doesn't it doesn't make sense
I'm not going to say it looks like a burnable bush
because it's the same
sprite I think that's not what
I don't mean the sprite
I mean the placement it just seems out of place
there's rows and rows
and rows of these bushes
that are like going on
in one direction if I remember correctly
and then there's just one
yeah you're right so that made me feel like
there's something that's what I'm saying almost
it's like it does have that
that Solomon's key factor
to it that we were talking about
where it's like if you look up the puzzles
it's not that gratifying
when you finally like
do it then because it's like
oh well now I'm just doing what I was
instructed to do
and this whole game is about not being
told to do anything
yeah you know
the hints in the game
in some ways
you know and I don't know
maybe we're praising
this game too much
but in some ways
like the mistranslations
of these things
like that make them kind of like
not direct English
enhances the hints too
because they're just
like now they're just vague hints
instead of telling us
directly what we should do
I don't know I think
I think that
the Burnable Bush
is borderline where I think
it's out of place enough that you will
experiment with it
I did I didn't know
what the candle did
so I didn't try to use it
I tried bombing the bush
and nothing happened
but I learned later
that you needed the candle for that
yeah and I will say too
I definitely had some
buried in me
I had some like subconscious knowledge
that like you're supposed to burn
the bushes to get on the thing
like if I were just
picking this up and I bought this
on day one it probably would have
taken me a lot longer to even know
that you could do
half this stuff yeah but like
I still think that
we may be praising it
too much because I still think that
even though I said
like oh it's part of the community thing
it's still like
where you have to
bomb what's the one
that you have to bomb a random wall
to get into oh yeah the final dungeon
the final dungeon like that is ridiculous
like there's another one too
it's there should be
a crack in the wall
at least for just that one
see the crack in the wall
I don't necessarily like
but I like something
placement wise
looking like
or a hint or something
if you think about it the crack in the wall
feels too no but there is
and there is stuff
like that though like there isn't a crack
in the wall in any of these
and some of those are just like
you know walls that you
wouldn't even think to bomb
but they only contain
in them like you know
someone giving you
rupees or like
you know it is a secret
it's a secret to everybody
yeah which is funny
because Miyamoto actually talks about
that in an interview
and this is a quick segue but
he talks about
how one of the
enemies
who says that
it's a secret to everybody
and gives you
the and gives you
the rupees he was saying like
yeah that's a secret
to everybody so it's like
our way of saying don't tell
your friends and stuff like that
but it's also like
he's saying that
in the game like don't tell
my fellow enemies
like it's a secret
to everybody like include
like let's just keep this between you
and me you know
and that actually
reminded me of one of the only
bad puzzles
in the game is
the level 7
dungeon
has that
enemy guy
the pig looking
thing that
just says like
you know grumble grumble
right and then it's like
there's no way
to find the meat
in that dungeon
you have to go
out to a merchant
buy the meat
and then
give it to him
to feed him to let him
to allow him
to let you continue
going through
the rest of the dungeon
yeah it is it is
and it's also like grumble grumble
I thought he was saying
that I didn't take it
as his stomach was grumbling
yeah they're just angry that I found the place
like cause it's one of those
like hint rooms I thought he was just
angry that I found it
other things
that like break it's own rules
like I know that there are
some rooms in
I forget which specific dungeon
but there are rooms in dungeons
that don't show up
on the map even though it's
like been established
that if there's a room
that you can like that you can't
have access to you can just bomb
the wall to get into that room
but it's not even
on the map
or there are only
like two blocks
that you can push or something
throughout the entire game
like these are just
weird discrepancies
that are fine
if they're leading
to side items
but if you need
to get through it
I think it should
follow like the
common knowledge that you've acquired
I agree yeah
and one thing
that I thought was really
very difficult to find on your own
and I'm trying to remember exactly
the method but to find
the seventh dungeon
you have to go
to one of those fairy pools
and like use an item
on the pool or something
what do you have to burn the pool
or something you have to use
the whistle on the fairy lake
you have to use the whistle
and then it turns
to sand instead of warping
you back so when you blow
the whistle in certain circumstances
a tornado comes by
and picks you up
oh really yeah like the same
tornado as Mario yeah that tornado
oh I didn't know that that's why I've been
calling it the warp whistle
I guess if you do warp
there's also a little
warp zone in this game
that I didn't know about until this playthrough
oh this take any
road you want the stairs thing
yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's a guy
one of the old men
instead of having three rupees laid out
he has three staircases
and so you can choose
any of the staircases and it'll take you
to a different part
and it's like a good way
to quickly traverse
the map from that point on
once you like know which one takes you where
wow that's something I never saw
all right guys so you know
we've been talking about
all the different dungeons and stuff like that
I guess now we should kind
of wrap this up by just
talking about the final
dungeon level nine
otherwise known as
death mountain which is a reoccurring
thing in almost every
single Zelda game
and this is where
you'll find Ganon
but one thing that I
thought was like
interesting about
like besides how hard
it is to figure out
that's where you have to go into
because you have to bomb that one
particular wall
I thought it was
interesting that this dungeon is so much
more complicated
and complex I feel like it's
almost as big as
the overworld exactly
it really is
it's gigantic
even the map
is like it's not even like
it's like the shape is
it's just like
there's so many
possible rooms
staircases too of like okay
so you know you're up in the
top right right now
but then you're gonna find the staircase that takes
you to the bottom left that gives you
like access to three new rooms
and then there's gonna be another
staircase and one of those it's
gonna take you to the middle
you know there's so many
different like
this just looks so
silly if you you know
if you look up a
map of level nine
on like Zelda dungeon
or something like that like if you
look up those things you're not
gonna believe what you're seeing
right and then
you you know
there's a couple of couple of
items in here to
get I think the
most important one
is the light arrows because
that's like that you need
those I think you need those
right to take
on the Ganon
the Ganon
and that's important
the Ganon not Ganondorf
Ganondorf is like
you know people want to say Ganondorf
because he's in Smash
but Ganondorf
is just like the the human
entity of Ganon
Ganon is the
real or like correct
I guess but it's spelled
differently in this
game why is it
G-A-N-O-N
it's G-A-N-N-O-N
oh okay is that the
correct no wait
really I think it's G-A-N-O-N
my copy
okay
or the way I
played it everybody has a
different experience with this game
do you know about
Ganon banning
yeah it's where
I forget which
form it is but if you spell
Ganon wrong they don't ban you
but it's called Ganon ban
what do they do so we've all just
been banned from that form
someone's reported
us so there's the
light arrows and then there
is the
oh sorry
they're called silver arrows
in this game
and then there's
the red ring too
because you probably already
have most likely
you'll have the blue ring by this point
and the rings
don't really
behave as rings they behave as
full outfits
yeah that give you
more defense legit
yeah they'll change
how you look and they boost
defense not offense
which I guess makes sense
because you have the swords to collect
to make you
stronger than that regard
so if the rings
and the swords just made you
stronger you'd have power creep
by the end of this game
I would just
like to confirm real quick
that in the
title crawl for Legend of
Zelda on NES
they spell
it G-A-N-N-O-N
oh wow
there you go so this game
should be banned
on that forum
they should not be allowed to
talk about the very first
Ganon maybe I had it
backwards and you do
spell the two N's Sam you're losing
my attention now
it's either they do it
or they don't do it
do they do it I don't know
anyway so one thing
that is interesting though is that
you can get into this dungeon
if you know about it
right at the very start
right so this is the idea
that like on your next
playthrough I'm just
gonna go right to
level 9 right
wrong you can go
in there you can get
all the way up to a certain
point and then the
old man's gonna be like
hey show me that whole
Triforce show me your
eight matches you know
and it's it's kind of
crazy but I guess
it is needed because if you
don't have the full Triforce
then it doesn't
make sense anymore yeah
then like you know
that's kind of like what you
needed to have the strength
to overcome Ganon
like that was in the story
in the manual at least
like the manual straight up
tells you go to dungeons
get pieces
of the Triforce because you need
the Triforce to save Zelda
so if you do
just wind up bombing that one
particular wall going straight
to Ganon and killing him and then rescuing
Zelda it's like well the whole
game essentially is meaningless
and then the game has an
existential crisis
and then the creator has an
existential crisis and then this
podcast doesn't
exist because that game doesn't
exist and no one
really cared about the NES because
Zelda didn't exist in the
first place and so the
system probably died after just
a few years so make sure
you get all the pieces
of the Triforce it's very important
everyone's timeline they all get
the we will fade
from every picture
that we've been in
if you don't get every piece of
the Triforce exactly
and so
it's really cool
because you show
up in the room with Ganon
you flash the
Triforce which I thought
was like really neat
you just like show it
you're like I have the
power and then Ganon's
like yeah but I can turn
invisible like he's also
like giant
you know not as big as
the three headed dragon
but he's a big
boy he's a big
pig he's husky
who turns invisible
and then like
shows up almost always
on top of you
deals an incredible
amount of damage
and takes
a good
amount of hits not as many
as I would have thought but a good
amount of hits to take
down and the
room is actually
shaped like a skull
too I thought that was
kind of neat and you
can also walk on
every tile
even though some of the tiles
are like blank where we've
been yeah to make
it look like a skull
but yeah that's interesting
actually I guess I didn't think
about that but yeah it doesn't
take too much to defeat Ganon
and then in the
very next room you'll encounter
Zelda and all will be
right she holds up
her triforce
as well yeah
but was that
also made of eight pieces
did she go to
another eight dungeons or maybe like
he just gave her half the triforce
she broke it up well they both
have a triangle but she broke up
your piece so that he couldn't
get it aren't there
alright so I'm Legend of Zelda
noob here I don't know
anything about it but
there are three
of these big
triforces or whatever
that like they each have one
right isn't like Ganon
Zelda and Link
all have a piece or you know
a piece of oh yeah
that's true to the lore
yeah is that in this game
though because I was looking through
and I wasn't
sure if that was no I don't
I mean like also the triforce is always
ever in three pieces
and no one's allowed
to have all of it
you know like that's the thing
but maybe in this one it's still in three pieces
but then also those three pieces get
separated into eight I kind of think
it's more like you know
how people have
those necklaces that like you get
with your friend and one of them
is half of a heart
and the other one is the other half
of the heart I think like
maybe the triforce
is just like half of like
a tri square
what wow
okay I dig it
I also like to think
that we shouldn't get too far into this
because then we start
talking about Zelda timelines
and that upsets
a lot of people because for
like almost a decade
Zelda fans
put in a lot of work
into making a timeline
that made sense
and then
Nintendo
like stuck their noses in
because they clearly
don't care too
for the record like they just
don't care
about like
a lot of things when it comes to like
explaining Mario this
explain Mario that
it's like yeah okay
well you know what now he's no longer
a plumber you know like
they just straight up said that at one point
like he's not a plumber
and it's like
he was
like okay like don't do that
so they stick their noses
into the Zelda timeline
and say like no this
is the like thank you
for your hard work
we'll consider that
when we make our official timeline
yeah that's sort of like how I feel
about I think that Disney
is getting a little
too big for their britches with Star Wars
and like they took away
all of like the
the expanded universe stuff
it's like no that's just fake stuff
yeah and it's like
we spend a lot of time
reading that stuff
and a lot of people
wrote books about
their games those books don't
mean anything they don't mean
nothing to us so more
and it's like the thing about
the timeline too
and how they made it
branch into three
separate paths
one of them revolves
around Link losing
oh good
like legit like there's a timeline
that is just built
around the idea that Link lost
in Ocarina of Time
and Ganon won
and like you
as the player so any game over screen
you ever got you've now created
that other timeline
where I actually don't remember
which timeline that is
because there's there's the Twilight Princess
I think that's the original Legend of Zelda
timeline oh yeah yeah
exactly that
you're right yes
see it's funny because this
as someone who hasn't
played any other games
this actually really
intrigues me yeah
like I do plan on playing all the games
and then you'll realize how dumb it is
it's all BS anyway
yeah yeah yeah it's all like
I think you know at the end of the day
just make up your own
yeah or how about this
okay let me blow your mind right now
The Legend of Zelda
this one that we're talking about right now
is pretty much
outside of Breath of the Wild
the last game
in the timeline
everything after this
takes place before it
I always thought about
these games as like
self-contained
and like they sort of like restart
every single time
but I guess it's just
there are a couple that are direct sequels
though are there
like Majora's Mask
is a direct sequel
to Ocarina yes yeah yeah
but I also just meant
like to Sean's point
it's almost like
it's just a fable
like it's told over and over again
Ganon always takes a different form
there's always Link
that has no recollection
of shit and Skyward Sword kind of clears that up
too with like the whole like
you know Ganon's not in that game
instead what's his name
Demise and he says that
he'll and he says
he's gonna do this
forever my descendants
will like
slaughter your descendants yeah they're like
bound together by eternity
Link, Zelda, and Demise
so it's like that like Bioshock Infinite
there's always a
we're not allowed to talk about
Bioshock Infinite because there was
five minutes where I thought
that game was really good
and I'm still upset
with myself I still like that game
it's bad
you're bad anyway
you're bad at video games
let's throw out their heart necklaces
now yeah
triangle squares
let's just talk
real fast about
what you would fix
so you've been
pretty much presented with a game
that a lot of people think is a 10 out of 10
one of the only NES games
that still is worth playing today
and now you're tasked
with like something
that you're gonna fix
what is that gonna be?
alright I can hop on this one
I think the
real basic thing
that just kinda got me
that took a lot of getting used to
is the sword strikes
and that you
there's no way to like
hit diagonally
and it's like
it's such a stupid thing
but you kinda have to like
make sure that you're like
moving up
and then exactly to the left
or exactly to the right
or moving down you know like
yeah I think
in the same vein
it's like just a tiny
tiny bit awkward
and they do fix it
in later games there is a timing thing
with this game
where I think in most games
that have this
like sort of top down view
if you press a direction
and
like the attack button
you're locked into
attacking in that direction
so
I would
like
try to try to attack an enemy
to the right and then immediately
like queue up
I'm gonna move down next
and I don't know if anybody else
noticed this but I would
try to attack the enemy of my right
and then queue up that that movement
and then I would just attack down
and I don't know
if anybody noticed this
that like you could sort of
change the direction
of your of your action
before the input
actually processed
on screen I feel like it's a very big
very small nitpick
yeah these are all little
little things for me too
but it was something
that like sort of had to make me
rewire that part of my brain
to like
just wait so nobody noticed that
no okay
I feel like there's a pretty precise
level I'm sure it happened
I noticed no I agree
but I feel like
level of attention
you're paying
to that
is pretty precise I noticed clunkiness
with the combat and with movement
like a little bit
so movement bothered me more
than combat like
there was just some times
where like I don't know
I guess like to your diagonal point
it just felt like
when I was trying to even like
maneuver myself to keep going
like upright upright
it was like sometimes that just
wasn't really registering
as well as I wanted it to
my fix
is something
that like I don't think
I personally can do
to the game
but just like a suggestion
is that
you know you have this
overworld where everything
pretty much happens with the exception
of the dungeons if backtracking
is ever going to be
like a thing that's like
required at any point
in this game like for instance
you were near the waterfall
and then much later
you find out
you know like oh
there was actually a thing over
by that waterfall I would just like
to see backtracking
be made more
interesting in this game
in the idea that like
now that you found
out that piece of information
there's another way
to get to that
same path without taking
the previous path
that you've now kind of like
done a few times
you know and I think like
that's a complaint you'll see from me
on a lot of backtracking stuff
is just because in general
I see backtracking
as more of like
a waste of time
on the player and maybe that's like
you know it's an immersion thing
for sure like you know
you're living in this world
you have to you want fast travel
you know but like
I'm saying yes
for me it's like
the fast travel thing
doesn't take away
anything from me
but I'm not saying do fast travel
I'm saying why not just have
another path
that you couldn't
have previously explored
but now that you have this piece of information
you can do it a different way
I have one last thing
yeah so like I do enjoy
playing this game but like
sometimes I felt
a little lonely and like
that I could maybe like
that I could have like some guidance
from like
maybe a character
smaller than me
that like
could just like tell me
what to do next
when you should listen oh my goodness
I'm sorry
it's so funny too
because if anything
like I didn't notice that
at all during the game
that I didn't have a companion
but now all of those
Zelda games where you have a companion
are just a little
more annoying because it's
it's just like a misstep
on Miyamoto's part
though like how could he
think that like because he heard
all of our complaints
about like wow we'll have to
bomb this wall
and then he just went overboard
I think they do a good job
with some companions but that's
no the character
like the characterization
of them even with the usefulness
of some I also don't know
if that's necessary like I would love
to see a version of Ocarina of Time
that doesn't give you any hints
or gives you
the same vague hints
that they gave you in the original
Legend of Zelda like I'd like to
drop into that world
you should play Minish Cat
because Ezlo
I think his name is
the hat he gives you
like vague hints as to where to go
but not how to get there
and that's pretty much
all he does I'm gonna have to
check it out your hat talks
yeah you have a
talking hat and in my head
he sounds like Gilbert Gottfried
okay alright so
here's some crazy
Zelda statistics
for you okay
by 1988
that's one year later
Zelda sold 2 million copies
now that's worldwide
and includes Japan's
86 part but like 2 million
wow it's a big number
okay like especially
back then for like video games
it sold 2 million
purchase of the game
included a warranty
and if you sent that warranty
to Nintendo
you got a free
subscription to the Nintendo
Fun Club newsletter
oh wow how long did that run
that ran
just a little bit before Nintendo Power
took over it was about a year
of like quarterly
stuff though so I think
they got like 3 to 4 issues
maybe and we will
cover that I don't think
like this this episode
is running long enough I don't think
we need to cover it here
but you know it's fun to read
that Q&A stuff and I've always
said I wanted to kind of do
that where we take the questions
from these Fun Club
and empower things and we
answer them instead of the
staff okay
I think that would be fun
so definitely look out for that
we will do that off
All right, and we're back.
Probably very fast for you guys, but we took a very nice break.
I had a glass of water.
It was two weeks ago that we last...
It's been two weeks, and I have prepared the developer interviews.
All of them with Miyamoto, because Tezuka really didn't have much to say.
So with that in mind, the first interview comes from around the time that they were finishing up development of the Super Famicom version of Link to the Past.
And so there was some reflection stuff on, like, what would you have wanted to do differently and stuff like that.
So the question, to be exact, was when you first started the development of the Super Famicom Zelda, did you have a specific vision in mind?
Like, you wanted the game to be a certain way?
Miyamoto. Zelda 1 had an inadequate system.
I wanted to do things that weren't capable of doing in the first game.
To call the first Zelda inadequate seems very harsh to me, the interviewer notes.
Miyamoto comes back with,
There were a lot of things we intended to do, but we kept getting blocked by hardware constraints.
So the interviewer presses for examples.
Miyamoto answers, For the level 7 dungeon entrance, we changed the color of the ground when the water drained, but we had originally intended to have the water actually disappear.
And you can burn small trees, but we intended for you to be able to burn down big ones.
There were a lot of little things like that, and I wanted the Super Famicom Zelda to be more realistic in that regard.
In addition,
Wait for it, wait for it.
In addition, back when Legend of Zelda was being made, having a world based on swords and magic was still a fresh idea, as was the concept of being able to save your game.
A system that allowed you to buy in-game items was also new, not to mention solving dungeons.
Also, I'm joking.
However, in the five years since the game's release, a lot of titles have appeared on the market that do that same sort of thing.
So the sense of innovation has disappeared.
I thought hard about what we could do next that would entertain the players.
On the other hand, we weren't just about to cut out shopping and dungeons entirely, just because they were no longer innovative.
Alright. My first, my first just like, basic question of this is, what is he talking about with the, the water disappearing?
Doesn't the water disappear?
Well, it turns into sand.
The animation. Yeah.
And then second of all, first of all.
What would be the use of burning down big trees?
Right. A lot of those things are so specific and seem unnecessary.
Things that he got stuck on, though, during development.
You know, it's like, to us it means nothing.
Right. But to him, he had another big plan ready to move.
I'm sure that was like hours of work.
It's like, why won't the big tree burn?
Like, we can't pull it off.
Yeah. And he probably wanted it to burn like, it would start off small and then get grand and bigger.
Scissors are floating up into the air.
They wanted like wildfire physics going on.
Well, I mean, they do have that later.
It's funny that you bring up the physics thing, though, too, because like in the Breath of the Wild, like the prototype build, they did make Legend of Zelda 1, like, but with Breath of the Wild physics.
Wow. Just to see like how that stuff would work.
Like, you know, like what if you put a tree on fire and then it spread, you know, like how it would.
So that's how they develop like what core concepts they wanted in Breath of the Wild by going back to the original Legend of Zelda.
And this prototype build will someday get out there.
I can only hope. Kind of wish they included it.
Like, I wish an area in Breath of the Wild was just the entire game of the original Legend of Zelda.
Yeah, that would be I mean, like in many ways there are like homages to the original Legend of Zelda.
And that even includes actually like I guess, you know, this is a stretch for me, but there is a small little island in the far northeast in Breath of the Wild that is very much like the island that you would take like your raft to get there.
Like it's like a square with like instead of being there's a labyrinth there now.
But like, you know, I like little nods like that.
That's cool. Do you guys want another quote?
Yes. Hit me. OK.
Play it again, Sam.
This is Miyamoto on just like, you know, how he approaches game design.
OK, I don't want to make games where the player is just a puppet in the hands of the creator playing exactly as scripted.
Trying to get players to become better and better at your game is certainly one valid approach to making games.
But for me, I want to present games to players that are more like pure toys, something you use, explore and play with freely.
And then the interviewer adds the Legend of Zelda took the RPG genre from a place of relative obscurity and made it friendly and easy to understand.
In that sense, it was a huge success for the gaming world.
What are your thoughts on that?
Miyamoto says, thank you.
For that one, I wanted to create a game world that conveyed the same feeling you get when you're exploring a new city for the first time.
How fun would it be, I thought, if I could make the player identify with the main character in the game and get completely lost and immersed in that world?
The idea of a game in real time also was something I'd been thinking about for a while.
But with such limited memory, it turned out to be a huge challenge to create enough satisfying content for players.
I absolutely wanted to avoid half-baked ideas and gameplay.
Since Zelda was released, I think the market has seen an increase in mean-spirited, petty games, and I still feel that sense of responsibility.
I have a couple questions.
When he says play in real time, did he want like a day-night cycle or something?
That would have been neat, right?
I think he just means more like the idea that you're living in a breathable world.
Instead of like...
Like some sort of breath.
Right, right. Like a wild breath.
Like a breath of the wild.
No, more like, you know how level 1-1 of Super Mario Bros., that's just as much of a world as Legend of Zelda,
except for in that one, things are scripted and they just happen.
I think he was looking more for like...
I think he's happy.
With the real-time world he created in the original Legend of Zelda.
But I'm sure he would have also, if the ability to have a day-and-night thing would have happened,
like he would have loved to do that.
He probably would have loved to also have like the times change.
I would interpret that also as like, you kill an enemy, it stays dead.
Yeah, that would have been interesting to see.
And like it just also is like laying there.
Oh, no, no, no. I mean, that's what happens though in the game.
You know? Well, if you're in a couple screens, I think.
If you're in a dungeon, I mean, you know, you're in a dungeon, you kill an enemy, and you clear a room, there are no more enemies in that room.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I meant that it would stay there dead.
Like if we could see it.
Yeah, because of course. That's a little bit.
It's a little bit much to me.
Real time, it would rot.
And what does he mean? That's that mean-spirited petty game.
I was going to say, what does he mean by mean-spirited and petty?
Just like more violent games?
Yeah. And especially because this interview that he's done takes place in like the late 90s.
So by then we're seeing like a rise in FPSs and stuff like that too.
And I think he's just more like, hey, like, you know, can we go back to making video games fun?
And it's like, Miyamoto, you're old.
Joe, did you have a thought?
Well, I was just thinking that if when I heard the mean-spirited petty thing, I thought he meant more like, I guess this is more games around that time period that Zelda came out.
But more like gameplay mechanics that are kind of cheap or you beat a game and it says, yeah, but do it all again before you really beat the game, even though that happened before.
But later, that's the same day.
Yeah, but later, that's the same day.
Considering the Zelda series as a whole, what themes are you trying to convey?
The cover art for the Famicom Legend of Zelda emphasized the feeling of exploration.
And I picked this one because I actually think Miyamoto has something to say this time around.
As an everyday boy gets drawn into a series of incredible events and grows to become a hero.
Within that framework, I wanted to create a game where the player could experience the feeling of exploration as he travels around the world,
becoming familiar with the history of the land and the natural world he inhabits.
That is reflected in the title, The Legend of Blank.
He includes the blank.
I don't. But I think that that's like a neat reason for why he would call the series The Legend of Zelda and like that whole framework.
But then goes on to add, adventure games and RPGs are games where you advance the story through dialogue alone.
But we wanted players to actually experience the physical sensation of using a controller and moving the character through the world.
We wanted dungeons to be explorable with a simple mapping system.
These and similar ideas were what we wanted to experiment with in Zelda.
These themes are carried forward in the Super Famicom Zelda as well.
I think he's mis...
He's not entirely giving an accurate description of what an RPG is.
Like, I think he's selling it short.
I think, yeah.
I think when he's talking about RPG there, he's probably more thinking like just tabletop gaming.
Just because you're talking about action.
And this is weird too because now at that interview point, we are in like 93, 94.
And so like there are like Dragon Quests and Final Fantasy out there.
So there is like another way to do RPGs.
But I, you know, I still, I like his like justification too for like how like gaming is like a different form of role playing than, you know, than tabletop gaming.
And like both are valid ways.
But here's what we try to do differently in video games.
And so just very briefly, this one isn't so much about Zelda, but I stumbled upon it on the Legend of Zelda developer interviews for the NES Classic.
This one is about the NES and what the NES, specifically the NES means to Miyamoto, Tezuka, and Koji Kondo.
And I thought that was interesting to hear like their thoughts on it because we're always talking about what the NES means to us.
So Miyamoto describes it as one word, competition.
Do we think of the NES ever as competition?
Not really.
To me, it's just like what existed.
Right. I think like in a way it almost like it dominated.
Yeah. I think of it as more like domination.
Yeah, yeah. Are they talking about like economic competition or are we talking about like multiplayer games playing against each other competition?
He's talking more like competition in the first sense.
Like the fact that like the competition between like games that you could make on the NES versus games you could make on a computer and games you could make on the Sega Master System.
Okay. You know, and like that the NES was like now entering the foray and was going to like establish a name for Nintendo as like a video game console maker, not just a heart, not just an arcade maker.
I think another part where for Kondo he goes, it's kind of a basis.
I've always worked in video game music and I think it's thanks to the NES.
So for him, in the days of the NES, I learned how to compose video game music and about the importance of sound effects.
Then along with the development of hardware, the sounds improved in quality and we were able to use a greater variety of sounds.
But when it comes to the essence of composing game music, the crucial elements haven't changed at all.
In that respect as well, I owe it to the NES that I'm able to write all kinds of music today.
Really interesting to think that he didn't have much of a music background before the NES.
Right. It's a very unique path in the musical career path.
I do think that having those limitations, you know, causes a lot of creativity though, especially when you're writing music.
Like when I'm doing the chiptune stuff, you, I mean, you have, you only have four tracks to do it with.
So you have to be really specific with what you want to do and it forces you to think in a certain way.
And when you have to think in a certain way, you kind of find like ways around obstacles that you wouldn't normally think about.
It makes sense why he's such a good video game music composer and why someone who like, and not saying that like normal musicians can't come on and, you know, try and score video games.
Because they have. Right.
They definitely have. And then some of them are great.
But I think like, you know, when you, when your whole life has been around just designing video game soundtracks, you come up with these, you know, weird quirks and ways of thinking about music to Sam's point that you wouldn't have thought about if you were coming from like a more like, you know, a rock and roll background or a classical background.
So that is interesting.
Even like, like a film, even if you're scoring films, I mean, imagine like you got, you got to think about in video game, you got to think about things being loopable or like making, you know, making sense in an action environment and not, you know, not kind of overtaking.
Right. Led Zeppelin wasn't worried about how their song would sound over and over and over again.
And then last but not least, I think Tezuka sums it up best how most of our listeners probably feel.
Tezuka thinks of it as a magic box.
It's a single device, but by changing cartridge, you can play something different.
Different software provides different experiences.
It's so small, but the NES Classic Edition is another magic box.
I mean, yeah.
Tezuka with the promo language there.
Yeah, that's what I kind of got at the end.
And I will link this whole article and interview into the show notes because Miyamoto then goes on a long rant about baseball on NES.
Quanted. As if, which is, but he goes into this long rant about it and how proud he is of it and like his sense of responsibility for it.
And I'm like, okay, dude, now it's 2017.
We really should not be looking back fondly at NES baseball anymore.
But Legend of Zelda does get a direct sequel for the Nintendo Entertainment System.
Legend of Zelda 2 Adventure of Link.
Yeah. And it's completely different than Legend of Zelda 1.
So we will be playing that and I'm sure we'll, you know, we'll all just love that one too.
Right, guys? I'm actually looking forward to that one almost more because I've heard so, so much about how different it is.
And I really don't know what to expect.
I know, I know one, one major element.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. And obviously like this, this thing's been like so many games after that too.
There's like, you know, besides like other just mainline games, there's a bunch of different, you know, like there's Hyrule Warriors now, which is a Musou style game.
But with Legend of Zelda characters, there's Triforce Heroes, which is with three people, you know, three people with 3DS is playing together.
Like Soul Calibur 2.
Soul Calibur 2, yes.
Link shows up in that one too.
And there's so many different ways that people think about Link now too.
Like I think of Link as the Soul Calibur 2 look, you know, like that adult Link that we see in like even the Super Smash Brothers games.
But like other people think of him as like the cel-shaded Wind Waker and other people think of him as like this young little boy in Legend of Zelda and Link to the Past.
Or like Big Burly Link from Legend of Zelda Future 9.
All right, I'll go for a spinoff.
I want to see one that is linear with branching story paths.
Oof. We haven't gotten that.
I don't want to see that at all. That's interesting, but yeah.
I know people disagree with that.
Like Telltale's Legend of Zelda?
No, no, not like that.
R.I.P. Like decisions that you make to decide what dungeon you go to or something.
Okay. You know? And not like...
But then you're locked out of other things because of that choice?
Yeah. Okay, interesting.
But there's enough that it doesn't matter and enough that you can replay it in a different way.
Yeah, and then at the end it just winds up like Mass Effect 3.
Yeah. Like all these amazing paths and then at the end it's just like, yeah, but the Crucible.
Okay, and then The Legend of Zelda also had a TV show.
Yes, The Legend of Zelda TV show with just like, honestly, we should have a podcast where
we just talk about the show itself.
Like that should just be a thing.
We all just watch the first season and just go over it.
The whole season? Yeah, the whole season.
How about the first episode? You really only need five minutes to get a grasp on it.
But all you need to know is, well, excuse me, princess.
Because that is Link's catchphrase.
There's a reason he doesn't talk in the games.
Right. It is insane that they gave him a voice.
And then also had him be like, yeah.
He's like a snarky guy.
He's very snarky.
Snarky guy from California.
It's almost like Peter Parker just took on Link's clothes and wound up in Hyrule because
he's trying to do that.
Even during the fights, he's very snarky.
And he's a little bit pissed off.
Yeah. Very weird.
And Ganon is also kind of like this weird blend of pig and human.
So he's not quite Ganondorf.
Still more Ganon, but he also talks and does a bunch of stupid garbage.
Well, he looks sort of piggy human-y in this game.
Yeah, no, I guess I just meant more like, you know, it's weird to hear him talking too.
Oh, okay. Does he wink?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He should be oinking.
Why don't they oink?
Zero out of ten. All right, we're almost done.
Zelda, Legend of Zelda is available on every kind of version you can think of too.
It's virtual console, everything.
Including the Life of Luxury edition.
What is the Life of Luxury?
Oh, yes, the new version.
The auto-cheat version.
Yeah, the new version that just came out for Nintendo Switch Online, Legend of Zelda SP edition.
As of this recording, it just came out.
Well, as of this recording, it just came out.
And you know what? I promised myself I wouldn't say that too.
That's why I wouldn't date this episode.
But whatever, you guys know when we filmed it now.
Sorry. Anyway, that version just lets it to this way.
All the optional stuff in the game that you can get before you ever go into any of the dungeons,
you just have at the very start of the game.
So this way you can just go over through the dungeons and clean house.
Max rupees too.
Yeah. I don't understand necessarily why they did this, but I don't hate it.
It's a separate load too, if that makes anybody feel better.
So you actually have to pick the SP version.
That's good. Instead of the regular files.
This way there's a reason to do both.
It's like, I can do it this way.
I can do it that way. I just hope they didn't do it because they thought kids today won't want to bother with it.
Because that totally defeats the purpose.
And it's only been 30 years.
Kids have not changed that much in 30 years.
Our expectations have changed.
Yeah, exactly. But it is a sign of what our expectations are now.
Interesting. I agree with that though.
I do understand that there's a different way to playing video games now.
But I still think that if you had a kid sit down with this game, they would be able to
figure this stuff out without me.
If they're playing the SP version, they're still willing to play the game.
So it's not like an unwillingness to play.
They're still willing to play the game. I just have this image, and maybe I'm just being a grouchy old man, but I just have this
image in my head of this kid, and he just starts off in the regular game.
He's like, where's my sword?
This game is stupid.
And then he just smashes the controller, and he goes upstairs.
Yeah, I imagine one of our listeners was like, hey, that was me.
Yeah. And then the last thing that I want to talk about, because no one really knows about this,
Zelda BS.
Does this ring a bell to anybody?
Zelda BS is for the Satellaview, which was an add-on for the Japanese Super Famicom, where
it was basically like the first DLC, where you basically paid a monthly subscription fee,
and then for an hour, this game would be live.
You could only play it for that specific hour, because it was transmitting the data during
that time. But it translated the original Legend of Zelda game, what a lot of people now call the third
quest, because it is like very...
There are some small differences between this, the second quest, and the third quest, which
is what the one that the Satellaview is referring to, where it is the original Legend of Zelda
game, with the combat and all, and the overworld style, and all the enemies, and the layout's
the same. But it's done in the Link to the Past style, similar to Super Mario All-Stars, you know,
like how Super Mario All-Stars remastered those.
There's this Super Nintendo version that no one can really play, except for me.
I managed to get a hold of this one.
You can also buy a reproduction cart of these online, but you're not funding anyone other
than the guy who makes the repo cart.
So, questionable if you want to do that.
And it's also like, it's not fully fleshed out, so I don't know if it's worth playing.
It's not a Super Mario All-Stars necessarily, but it's neat that they have this, right?
16-bit original Legend of Zelda?
It's neat that you have that, Mike.
Well, I don't own it.
In fact, nobody can own that game, if you think about it, because the Satellaview, like
you couldn't even transfer that data to your cartridge.
You needed to just be online at that specific time.
Wow. That's interesting.
It's also, it makes sense that it failed.
Yeah. That's a Satellaview in general, yeah.
What does the BS stand for?
You know, it's like, yeah, I know it sounds like bullshit, but it's actually like a Japanese
thing. Like, the BS does stand for something, but not something I can tell you.
And by me saying the third quest, I realize we completely skipped over the second quest,
but I think that we've skipped over that for good reason, because that is kind of like
an entirely another way to play this game.
Maybe one day we'll do like a fun bonus episode where we talk about the second quest.
Maybe it's just the same thing, just rearranged, right?
Yeah, it's rearranged, but it's also like, you know, you can get that anyway, too.
You can have like a ROM hack make a randomizer for you, you know, where you can just have
everything spread out differently.
You can do the third quest, fourth quest, fifth quest, sixth quest.
But I think it is nice that they included this as an option, because it is, you know,
it is fun in the sense that you know everything you need to do, but the order that you find
these things, the enemies, the layout, you know, the dungeons are different.
So I think that that's kind of cool that they decided to do that in a sense of like, okay,
so I know I need the magic sword, but it's not where it should be.
Or like, I know I need to get the, you know, to get this thing to do that, but it's not in
that location. I think that's pretty neat that they went with that design choice.
It's different than like when Super Mario Brothers finished, and at the end of the game,
all you do is press B to like choose which world you want to go to.
In this sense, it's like, how about a whole new world?
A whole new world.
Especially back in the time when you only had so many games to play.
You only had so many games to play, so you were like, oh, I get more, I can, you would
have more time to sit down and play through Legend of Zelda again.
Nowadays, you would be charged for the second quest.
Right. You know, so it's nice that they included it.
Nowadays, you'd be charged for the middle of the first quest.
All right. We're out of ideas.
So with that, it's time for the Essential Games List.
All right. It's time for the Essential Games List, guys.
You don't have, you know, we've been talking so much about this game.
I'm not asking for essays.
You know, you can vote if you want to.
You can say something fun.
You can shout out to mom.
Whatever it takes.
Just tell me, is Legend of Zelda worth playing today?
Sean? I abstain.
Wow. I, um, no, I, yeah.
No, I mean, it's still definitely worth playing today.
Uh, it's, uh, one thing I forgot to mention, and this is, this is very small, but it's got
my favorite heads up display so far, where it's got like all the information you need
right there. Um, and, uh, you know, that's, that's what put it over the edge and put it on the Essential
Games List. Nice.
But it is essential, yeah.
Joe. All right.
So I am afraid that I do have a little bit of an essay.
I'm ready. Um, and, and it, we already talked about the game play and the design and everything,
so I want to talk about something a little different.
Um. The pause sound.
The pause, I actually don't even know if I ever paused this game.
Select pauses, that's why.
Oh, that's what does it, yeah.
Um, but you know, no, we, the game has such a level of freedom and exploration, and like
you explore to find your way, and you explore to, like I, like I mentioned earlier, you feel
like you are thrown into this world that just exists around you, it doesn't exist for you.
Um. So it, that kind of like lets you project yourself onto the, onto the character, onto the situation.
And I know that there is a story in the manual, but it, it really feels like you're kind of telling your own story.
Like, it feels like you experienced this because you, you choose your path and you, you know, you decide while you're playing, like, you know, what's Link thinking right now?
You know what I mean? Like, there's no cut scenes or there's no.
There's not even a voice.
Right. There's not a voice.
You, you. You are that character.
And you name them. Exactly.
And like, like I said, you, you can have different experiences from your friends.
Um. I'm sure a lot of people relate to this, but when I was a kid, I felt the need to make everything an adventure in my head.
Like, everything, like I, I wanted to feel like everything was, you know, I was going on some crazy adventure.
And this game really gives you that feeling.
When you went to school, was it an adventure?
It was an adventure. In my head.
Imaginary. An adventure to learn.
Even for, like, in second grade during recess, I would actually, like, my brother happened to, like, have recess with me too.
And he's my younger brother.
And we would, um, we would actually do, like, Legend of Zelda for recess, you know?
Like, like, not playing it either.
Just pretend it, like, LARPing it.
Yeah. I think we all had that phase, right?
Oh, yeah. For a long time.
Yeah. Probably too long.
But, um, I think that as much as I love, like, a, like, a thick plot and a, you know, a lot of character arcs and twists and turns and everything.
And granted, there are, there is a plot in this game, but it's subtle.
So, it, I think the reason I, the reason I like that stuff is because I, I want to, I want to be a storyteller.
So, it's, it's cool to, to kind of feel like you're, you're telling the story.
I guess to sum it all up, I think that this game works so well because it, it, like, pairs with your imagination, which a lot of games don't do as well anymore.
Uh, and I think that that's, on top of the gameplay and on top of the design, that's, like, the biggest reason that makes this essential.
All right. There you have it.
Uh, two votes. That puts it in.
But, Sam, let's hear some thoughts.
All right. So, when I first heard that we were playing Metroid in 1987, I got really excited.
And then, when we played Metroid, I'd still voted it essential, but I was kind of underwhelmed by, like, you know, it wasn't as good as I thought it would be.
And it was a little bit, like, frustrating, and there were some parts that I didn't, I wasn't really crazy about.
And that was the last game that we played going into this one.
But when we went into, when I started playing this one, it was immediately, like, I could tell this is, like, I knew immediately it was essential.
You know, it was just, like Joe was saying, I mean, you kind of hit everything.
It's, uh, there's just, like, a feeling of freedom that you get with this game where you have to just figure stuff out on your own.
And you know that maybe I can get past these guys this time, you know, but maybe they'll probably kill me because they're really strong.
Um, and these are, there are all these different things that you just have to kind of figure out how to play the game.
And if you want to, you can say, okay, I can sneak by these guys.
And you can just, you can play it however you want to, like, you know, to a certain, uh, to a certain extent.
And the fact that they're, like, this kind of game didn't ever exist before it, like, in this, like, built this way, you know, is just, I don't know.
It's just, it's a brilliant game.
The core mechanics of it are just very solid.
And it's a really fun game.
I would say that even if you're not, like, like, I know that the essential games list is for, like, if you want to play the NES, like, these are the games that you should play.
But I would say that everyone should play this game, at least for a little bit.
There you have it. Another yes vote.
All right. I'll try to make this a little brief.
But I think, like, one thing to note is, first off, the length of this episode, and we still haven't covered it all.
Think about it. Like, I had to, like, briefly assign about the second quest.
We didn't talk about, like, how neat it was that you could save.
Like, think about how many games we've complained about that you can't save.
And now we finally have one that you can.
And it's like, yeah, we'll just mention that at the very top and then forget about it.
I instead, since we're talking about the essential games list, I kind of want to throw this back to Breath of the Wild for a minute.
And talk about, like, a lot of people right now will have that as, like, you know, their game of 2017, their game of the decade.
Maybe it's their favorite game of all time now.
Now, it's so interesting having played Legend of Zelda first, then Breath of the Wild, and now coming back to Legend of Zelda.
It's so interesting to see, like, how these games that are 30 years apart from each other, more than 30 years, I think.
Yeah, 31 years apart from each other are still, like, so good for two completely different reasons.
One is completely redefining how modern games should be played, and the other one completely redefined how modern games should play in its time, you know?
And yet, they find core similarities in just the way that they let players explore, experiment, try different things.
And, like, yes, there are other games that let you explore a world.
There are other games that let you fail and try different ways.
There are other games that don't give you such obvious clues.
But the difference is that the way that the game, the way that the gameplay, the story, the control of you, you know, on this character, that's never been done before either one of those two games, you know?
Like, Legend of Zelda did it in a way that no one had done it before.
And so, yes, there will be games that come after it.
But the fact that, like, the games that come after it can only really ever be just as good, you know?
Or, like, oh, they do this specific thing better, but they're lacking in this area, you know?
It's, like, we're gonna see Zelda-likes that just, like, don't quite, like, you know, they almost feel like cheap imitations, you know?
We're gonna see that.
And, yes, there are better things, you know?
Like, something comes to mind for me is, like, Binding of Isaac, where it's, like, that's just a dungeon, like, that's just the dungeons of Legend of Zelda made into, like, a full game where it's randomized and you never know what's gonna happen, right?
It's, like, that's the idea behind that.
And that's, like, a great execution on that.
But that game can't exist without Legend of Zelda.
And now with Breath of the Wild, you have, like, this whole, like, when we say you can go anywhere, we mean it, you know?
And it's, like, still, that hasn't, like, you know, give it some time, but that hasn't been done in games since.
Like, the ability to actually just go wherever you want, like, you could go straight to the ending right from the beginning.
There are many games where the map is wide open, but please continue.
No, no, no, I'm saying, like, you know, because, like, if you can scale it, like, you see that mountain, like, you can scale it.
And that's, like, it right from the very start of the game.
Like, there's no item required.
I'm saying, like, does a game let you do that?
I mean, like, Grand Theft Auto.
Any open world game is like that, isn't it?
Grand Theft Auto, like, I'm saying, like, they don't lock any, like, immediately when you start the game, you can go into anything and do that thing.
Like, you're not locked behind, like, missions.
I think in Grand Theft Auto V, you can just sort of ride around to the entire map.
Or even, like, Just Cause 2, the whole map's open.
But I'm not trying to do what you're talking about.
That's not what I'm saying.
I am saying, all I'm saying is, is that I think the difference between Breath of the Wild and, like, a Just Cause 2 is, like, in Breath of the Wild, the story can be completed in any particular way.
So, like, you can just head right to it.
No, no, no. But involving, too, like, the idea that, like, if you see it, you can go to it.
It's like, well, the castle's where all the stuff's going down, so I'm just going to run right there and do it.
I don't think you can do that in Just Cause 2 and Grand Theft Auto because I think, like, there's certain missions that need to be completed and certain things that need to be done before you can get to certain parts in the game.
Whereas, like, Breath of the Wild says, like, you want to go to that dungeon?
Go to that dungeon. You want to go to that dungeon first?
Go to that dungeon. Like, there's a freedom of opportunity to go anywhere and do anything.
Okay. That, like, games haven't done yet, but I'm sure games will eventually be, like, that climbing thing that Zelda implemented to make it so you can scale over any wall?
Like, we need to have that in our games.
You know, like, it's going to become a mechanic.
I think that, like, you know, they worked in the game for seven years and we haven't seen it yet done elsewhere because, like, it's going to take some time to implement that.
But the same way that, like, we're not going to see another Legend of Zelda clone for a while.
We're not going to see another one in 87 for sure.
But eventually they're going to start coming out and we're going to be like, oh, now people are finally catching on.
This game sold 2 million copies by 1989.
You know, it's like, or 88.
2 million copies.
Like, and it's still selling copies.
And if you look at Nintendo Power, even when the Super Nintendo was out, it was on top 10 lists, you know, like, still as bestsellers.
Like, that's, like, a testament to, like, people would buy this game and it would just be something you needed to have for this system.
So, of course, it's essential.
It's essential because everybody who has an NES probably thinks, like, if they don't own this game, it's, like, at least on their list of something they need to buy.
It's not a rare game by any means.
You go on eBay. You bid for it.
You know, you get it. Like, you find it at a, you know, you probably don't find it at a garage sale, to Joe's point, because everybody's holding on to their copy.
Like, this is a game that people still want to play today.
And it's not so short that it's not, like, worth getting.
But it's also not so long that it's not worth trying.
Like, you know, you might not finish the game.
That might, like, to Sean's point, you know, he was playing as long as he could.
And then he just, like, he hit a wall.
And he was like, you know, someday I'll come back to this game.
But for right now, this is my story.
It's like, that's an appropriate way to play this game, too.
It's like, play up to what you can.
Yeah, I think this game is satisfying to beat.
But it's also...
Satisfying to play. Yeah, it's not unsatisfying if you don't beat it.
It's still satisfying to have played it.
I think, yeah, I think that's, like, a huge testament to the game, too, is that, like, if you get stuck at any particular point, it's like, yeah.
And that was, like, kind of the idea, was that you would get stuck.
You would try new things.
Like, weird that it becomes acceptable when it's implemented the right way.
Yeah, playing the game is the good part of the game, which I think is cool.
Right, right, which is cool.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's not like there's a part where it's like, oh, it's this part.
This part sucks. But then again, we talked about the game for a very long time now.
And talking about it was just as fun.
Right? Yeah. I think that's it, unless, Joe...
Small clarification I want to make on my...
I said that the story is subtle.
And I mean the story...
Well, what's being told to you while you're playing...
I was going to say that's a very generous description of the story.
I saw the look, and I was like, okay, the story in the manual is anything but subtle.
Yeah. But the story that you are telling yourself while playing it is subtle.
Like, they... It's...
Yes, it's another...
It's another Breath of the Wild note, you know, where it's like, that game has like,
I think, 12 cutscenes total, which is 12 more than the original Legend of Zelda.
But I think a lot of people complained about the lack of a story, and it's like, why don't
you just come up with your own story?
And that is all the time we have for this episode of Nostalgia.
Thank you so much for listening all the way through.
We definitely made this one an extra...
An XL version.
I'd like to also apologize to everybody about my sickness.
I'm sure that was distracting, but it just had to be, you know?
Sometimes you're just sick.
Yeah. You know? I'm sure, like, for that one listener who's like, actually, I'm never sick, you know?
It's like, well, tell us what you take.
Yeah. Because it's just Zycam?
Because if it's just Zycam, then I guess I should do that.
You know, there's like those shots that you can get.
This is not a promo for anything, but there's like those allergy shots you can get.
But you have to take them for, like, years before they, like, really kick in.
Aren't those just for, like, cats?
I think they're just for allergies.
Like, you know, I think... Yeah, like for allergies.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, okay.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Again, not a promo for the allergy people.
What a way to end the Zelda episode.
And you know what else I like to check out for years and years?
www.nostalgiacast.com.
That's the place where you can find...
It's still up there. You inject it straight into your arm.
What? You inject it straight into your arm.
Yeah, you're going to just take a USB and inject it straight into your arm.
Please don't do that.
I think if you say please don't do that and someone does it, they can't sue you.
It's true. Because you told them not to.
This is a digital brand. You're going to need a Thunderbolt cable.
You know, I don't even have to finish my other point because I already said the name of the website.
So they know that there's stuff there.
I don't have to tell them what's there.
But where can they find you on the Twitter?
They could find us on Twitter at atnostalgiacast.com.
And you can find me at EspositoFilm on Twitter.
That's what I meant. And I'll talk to you soon.
Bye. Bye.!